intentemos restar 659 a 971 tan pronto
como empecemos a hacerlo nos
encontraremos con un problema fíjate en
el lugar de las unidades como restaremos
9 al 1
la solución es reagrupar esto significa
que tomaremos una cantidad prestada de
otro lugar y la usaremos en el lugar de
las unidades para que entiendas mejor
esto permíteme reescribir estos dos
números del lado derecho haré la
descomposición de los números el 9 está
en el lugar de las centenas por lo que
representa 900
el 7 está en el lugar de las decenas
entonces representa
siete decenas o setenta y el uno está en
el lugar de las unidades
entonces representa uno
en el número de abajo tenemos lo
siguiente el 6 representa 600
el 5 representa 5 decenas o 50 y el 9
representa 9 unidades o nueve estamos
restando 650 más 9 u otra forma de verlo
es que estamos restando 600 restando 50
y restando 9 resolvemos acá la operación
es el mismo problema pero escrito de
forma diferente todavía tenemos el mismo
problema cómo restar un número más
grande a uno menor la solución es tomar
prestada una cantidad de otro lugar y en
este caso el lugar más conveniente es el
de las decenas
aquí tenemos 70 porque no tomar 10 de
aquí que quedaría entonces en 60 y
prestárselo al lugar de las unidades
si sumamos 10 + 1
esto queda como 11 es importante que te
des cuenta que no hemos cambiado el
valor del número 971 es igual que 960 +
11 y ahora ya podemos restar 11 menos 9
son 260 menos 50 son 10 y 900 menos 600
son 300 el resultado de esta resta es
300 más 10 más 12 o 312
muy bien ahora vamos a realizar el mismo
procedimiento que hicimos aquí de
nuestro lado izquierdo donde no hemos
hecho descomposición de los números
mismo problema como restamos 9 al 1
tomemos 10 del lugar de las decenas y
reagrupamos desapareceremos entonces una
decena de aquí lo que dejará con 6
decenas a este lugar y le prestaremos
estos 10 al lugar de las unidades 10 más
1 son 11 y entonces ya podemos restar 11
menos 9 son 26 menos 5 es 1 y 9 menos 6
son 3 312 obtenemos